this year ladies and gentlemen we lost a  member of the Star Wars family the great  Peter Mayhew passed away of course we  all loved whose portrayal of Chewbacca  and by all accounts he was a really  great guy who was loved by his fellow  Star War cast members so tonight we're  gonna do something to honor Peters  memory I thought I'd be fitting to give  him the send-off he deserves this is  something that can only happen here at  comic-con a 21 Wookiee salute  [Applause]  we went down to comic-con floor  [Applause]  ladies and gentlemen we went down we  witnesses for real we went down to the  comic-con floor and we found 21  cosplayers in wookie costumes these are  all real they're here tonight they came  on the spur of the moment to honor the  original Zhu bakka Peter Mayhew ladies  and gentlemen are you ready  all right wookies begin your salute  nicely timed Whoopi's rest in peace  Peter may